heard always is you know turn the other
cheek that's the only one that I that I
always hear all right if that's the case
if Jesus when he said turn the other
cheek and he meant all right hey
uh you can't protect yourself and defend
yourself or arm yourself in order to
protect your loved ones in you can I ask
you a
question go ahead
okay here's what I want to ask
you John 18 you
ready yeah go to John 18 read for me 20-
23 do you believe Jesus practices what
he
preaches yes okay read for me John 1820
to
23 okay 20 to
23 okay it says Jesus answered him I
spake openly to the
world I ever taught in the
synagogue and in the temple whether Jews
always Resort and in secret have I said
nothing why ask thou me ask them which
heard me what I have said unto them
behold they know what I
said and when he had thus spoken one of
the officers which stood by struck Jesus
with a the palm of his hand okay now
watch answering before you go on so the
high priest
servant slapped Jesus right right now
Jesus should have turned the other cheek
right right but what did he
say if I have spoken evil bear witness
of the evil but if I if well why smile
smilest thou me why did Jesus complain
and not turn the other
cheek why didn't Jesus practice what he
preached he got smacked instead of
turning the cheek he complained and told
him hey if I spoke the truth how dare
you hit me
why you're silent brother I'm not sure
because that's not his point turning the
cheek doesn't mean if someone hits you
then just let him beat you and bloody
you and de that wasn't the point because
here Jesus got hit and he said if I
spoken the truth why do you hit me he
didn't turn the other cheek because
that's
misunderstood when you read that passage
carefully when Jesus says if someone
strikes you with his right someone
strikes you on the right cheek give him
your left right that's what he says if
someone strikes you on the right cheek
give him your left okay if most people
are right-handed if most people are
right
right-handed if they're going to hit you
on the right cheek what side of the
right hand are they going to hit you
with hit you
with the backside yeah po right in the
street you know what we call that
right yeah yeah I'm gonna have to give
the G-rated version in the street bi
slap what Punk okay most right handed
people if they're going to hit you in
the right cheek it means they're going
to have to hit you with the back of the
hand hitting someone the back of the
hand is a very degrading insulting way
it's like saying you're not a man you're
like a little girl someone to backhand
you
right okay so then what Jesus says is
give him the left meaning it is a
metaphorical way of saying don't repay
insult for insult if someone insults you
let him insult you do not retaliate in
kind that's all he's saying
gotcha okay right yeah that makes sense
that's all he's saying this is simply a
metaphorical way of saying if I backhand
you that means I'm degrading you I'm
saying man you're not even a man you're
like a little because if you're a
man we duke it out but this is what I
think of you be
SL right don't let me backhand you in
other words by backhanding you I'm
insulting you saying you're not even man
enough so I'm insulting you so this is
the Lord's way of saying this is the
Lord's saying way of saying don't return
insult for insult let him insult you
don't stoop to their level that's all
he's saying that's all he's saying